Good morning John, I'm making an album.
It is terrible sound in here, let's fix this - that's better.
Sometimes, John, you have to make sacrifices. And today I'm sacrificing good video for good audio.
I wouldn't be doing that if I wasn't talking about my album,
but I want you to know that I'm dedicated to making things sound good
Maybe I can bump the ISO up a little bit
Now I need to fix the white balance
As good as we're gonna get
So how am I gonna make an album?
Well, with some of my favorite musicians from the world,
including the guy who films, edits, and directs Crash Course Chemistry, Nick Jenkins,
Rob Scallon, of the Rob Scallon YouTube channel,
Joe DeGeorge, of Harry and the Potters,
and Andrew Huang, of Songs To Wear Pants To.
Let's let them introduce themselves
My name is Andrew Huang and my channel is Songs To Wear Pants To, where many musical adventures take place
What's the weirdest type of music you've ever made   ?
Someone told me to make a sexy song about airplane terminology
Who are you?
I'm Joe DeGeorge
Or like a chancellor, it's a democratic state.
I'm Rob Scallon, and I play guitar a lot.
I rule Giza. So the pyramids are mine.
How do you feel about slavery there?
Ah...
Obviously heavily bro.
What about you?
I'm the card dealer
Now I'm not
You wouldn't actually know the world's fastest clapper?
I really do. We have one YouTube video that's on my second channel.
Can I use - cut footage - to it here?
Yeah Yeah
That makes me interested.
What super weird skill do you have?
Comments. I wanna make a video montage of all the weirdest skills
What's your weirdest skill?
No one else in the world can do this,  I can flip my eyelids up
Wait, what?
Well, you see the difference between this...
and this?
Yes
Oh!
Yeah, right?
Oh
I can
Oh wow,  I can do this
This one's for the ladies
So what weird thing can you do?
I think this would be an amazing collab video, for all of us in the world
Going really well so far. They're really talented.
I'm really lucky to be able to work with them.
Some songs you've heard, some songs you haven't.
We're gonna be covering some songs.
It's pretty cool,  I kind of have a band right now.
Which I've never had before.
All right, thank you, Mr. Tao for improving my sound quality, for making the video super weird,
and thanks to Nick, and Andrew, and Joe, and Rob, for making music with me.
John,  I'll see you on Tuesday.
And yes, this is the last day of the 12 Days of Pizzamass, so go buy your pizza things now,
they will never be available again, except maybe the like number one top-selling thing. I'm not sure.